well DC fans Ezra Miller is probably not
going away so there is an upcoming
episode of a podcast called the
discourse the full episode isn't out yet
but part of it has been released and is
confirmed as authentic that involves an
interview with the director of the
upcoming Flash movie Andy machete and
his wife and the producer of the film
Barbara machete who both said that if
there is a sequel and if they're
involved they will have Miller back so
this is not a 100 confirmation because
it's ultimately not their call on
whether a sequel happens so it's
possible a sequel may not happen at all
it's also possible that if the this pair
of creators decide to put their feet
down and be like we won't be involved if
we can't work with Ezra Miller it's
possible that the people above them will
go fine you walk away we still want to
recast we bring in somebody else but it
is one more thing that is indicating
that it's likely Ezra Miller is going to
remain in the part of the flash folks
will make their own Comfort on whether
or not they're okay seeing that but I
think we need to acclim it to that
reality at this point